good morning everybody and welcome back
to office hours for CS 256 mobile web
development i'm here with Sean Bennett
course architect at Udacity and chris
wilson the developer advocate that the
chrome developer relations you know
myself program manager the chrome
developer relations team so we're back
the second episode for answering all the
questions that you've been asking online
last of the question last week we have a
lot of questions and they all came in
during the show which is great and from
all over the world to so in the US we
had a long weekend we had martin luther
king day yesterday I think her quite a
few people were off and we're off to a
bit of a slow start yet but we've had
our coffee and we're ready to answer
some questions so this week we're
answering questions about lessons four
and five and those are the fluid design
and flex box and media queries lessons
and Sean tell us a little bit about the
work you've done on the fluid design or
flexbox the problem sets like you came
up with a pretty interesting flexbox
demo yeah by the way down yeah so I mean
when we were trying to figure out how to
teach this and figure I mean we went
back and forth on this a few times like
figuring out how to get this across to
users with no that wasn't many property
yeah it started feeling like this long
list of well there's this property yeah
you can use it this way this way on this
way and it was really did not feel very
and at first it was basically just you
talking through all of them one at a
time to the student yes and I remember
you coming out like halfway through and
you're just like this this is not going
to like this it felt like a lecture that
is not even and is never going to have a
gleam interesting lecture yeah so we
were trying to figure out how to change
that around and
kind of came up with this this
interactive experience using the chrome
dev tools which i think is way better
than just talking at you nobody wants to
hear that well we still hear that yeah
her ma yeah so how does that work Sean
so you're actually in the chrome dev
tools yeah yeah I mean it's basically
just an iframe that listens for your
input on it on the page in the iframe
and then you change properties of it in
the chrome dev tools and when it happens
we fire off events and and fire off a
web audio events which chris might know
something about but it was actually
surprisingly easy to get something
simple up and running making it work
across the board and making it into a
decent experience was quite a bit harder
you did spend a lot of time or it's not
quite perfect yeah it's not working in
all the browsers yes that was always a
child had tricked out tools oh no but
yeah but I I think the more we can do
that moving forward into the future the
better I thought it was a really cool
experience yeah exactly yeah that's
really cool well that's great the power
of devtools is just getting more and
more it's getting crazier and crazier
yeah after you can edit it so it feels
well great well I wanted to just jump
into the questions first one is from SF
in the Netherlands my home country this
is actually Hugh is yeah it is it's not
it's not this way so mother speaking of
chrome devtools speaking of chrome dev
tool there isn't a warning that pops ok
when you use DPI so consider using DPP x
instead of Li PP our DPI as in CSS DPI
should we use d PX e m dpi or percentage
one
what very subtle question but also in
the interesting thing is you know this
isn't anywhere near the entire list of
units either right now actually you know
go through all of them so this question
I i believe is really about what you use
to declare your media queries because
these are I can't remember that the
precise term for them but they're the
resolution types i think is what they're
called so the difference between DPP x
and DPI is essentially how many haha how
many actual device pixels there are /
CSS pixel um so the big difference
between DPI and DP P X is whether or not
it takes in that that Retina screen
multiplier or not which on mobile is
sort of important we'll talk a lot more
about this in lesson 6 on adaptive
images responsible images realistically
in this particular case you if you're if
you're shifting on DPI you're probably
having to take responsive and retina
displays and that sort of thing into
account that's probably what you're
trying to do and either one of them will
work you just have to figure out you
know what the weather you want that
multiplier built into your media query
or not so if you want to get actual
physical inches on the screen then you
use DP I and if you want if you want
well what's the rough resolution of my
screen but let that but how'd that be
with the the weird the second time I
said that the system is lying to you in
this this past lesson that that's the
multiplier I was talking about as for
the rest of the unit types you know when
you define how big something is on the
screen should you use ems pixel or ems
PX percentages points whatever i mean
the best advice I can give is be
consistent because if you tend to mix
these units you're going to find that
some of them scale one way on a you
it on some devices but they scale
differently on different devices or my
personal favorite that weird thing where
when you rotate an iphone it zooms up
the unit types if you haven't carefully
defined them with a reset style sheet
and that sort of thing so be consistent
and really any of them again will work
they just they will rescale slightly
differently EMS and and percentages are
approximately the same px is not
actually as bad a unit as it used to be
on mobile devices at least because it
does get scaled it's not really a pixel
it's not really a screen pixel in fact
even on a lot of desktops now desktop
browsers they started certainly on the
Chromebook pixel a pixel is not a
physical pixel or all your web pages
were really small and that's true on
retina display macbooks as well so you
know there there's there's a lot of
complexity and CSS units I think you'll
find in this particular case DPP X is
probably you know just off the cuff if I
have to give a solid answer it say yeah
follow the chrome devtools advice but
it's not totally wrong to use DPI either
it's not this isn't an error right it's
just a warning right now great well
encaustic so next question from Varun in
Chicago so I think you might have
something to say about that Sean flexbox
support is not there and every browser
in flexbox it was still not standardized
what is the motion motivation behind
using flexbox for this course and what
are the other options so I think one of
the first things i would like to throw
in there before you yes is one of the
ways to get a good sense of what
supported and we mentioned it in the
course is used a can i use site can i
use com yeah great site for quickly
checking how far out yes yeah editor's
that you're using yeah and if you want
to get a good sense of like how much
usage each browser gets and right like
I'm kind of a visual scale I'd recommend
using the beta version of that right 10
usage relative which actually gives you
a very clear visual representation
what user how many users would I
actually be able to support exactly I
used this otherwise it gets really yeah
a percentage yes otherwise they're all
right even and it just gives you a
percentage which is not as clear beta
ninety percent of the browsers support
it but you know the browsers that don't
are over naive thank you yeah right so
yeah you should definitely use that on
on the aspect of actual flexbox support
it's actually relatively high if if you
consider the old flexbox models as well
so flexbox has gone through a number of
specification changes and he's right
that it's not quite standardized
although I think the current version is
pretty close to it the good thing is you
can actually polyfill most of this into
the old specifications using either less
or SAS mix-ins or using a build step
before when you're compiling your CSS
using something like auto prefix er
which is pretty cool it'll basically
auto fill all of not just for flexbox
but for essentially all of your CSS
it'll auto vendor prefix and you can
specify what versions of what browsers
you want to support it's pretty cool if
you use something like that then right
out of the box you get essentially all
of the modern browsers and then also
back to IE 10 so you don't get a 29
which is a problem there is a real push
toward this standard or two because
right flexbox is such a fabulously
useful tool yeah and I remember back
after ie6 when I was in the Internet
Explorer team we set off to do this what
became the dotnet framework 3.0 and we
were building the rendering and layout
system for it I mean we looked at all
kinds of application user interface and
it turns out something like ninety-five
percent of all of the app you I was
basically either a what is essentially
flexbox you know flexible stacking boxes
or grids
that's it like those are the two main
tools you need and the fact that CSS
hasn't really had this easily usable
flexible stacking boxes system for so
long it's kind of a pain in web
developers and there are ways to do
things that are similar to that like
floating boxes obviously and if you
really really need to be running on
every last old download downgraded
browser you probably want to use those
tools mm-hmm but it is going to be a lot
more challenging yeah and flex box and
that that's one of the big things is
developer time yes I mean developer time
I can whip up just about any simple bit
like standard layout for a for a web app
throw at me very quickly yeah with
flexbox absolutely whereas if I had to
do the same thing with you know floating
boxes and all that then it would take a
significant amount more time so what you
should really look at is what is what is
the demographic for your actual app what
users are coming to your page with what
browsers and is it worth your time to
actually support those or can you
support them well enough yet with with
something downright Hills or something
and again there's also if you absolutely
do have to support older versions of
browsers there's also you know
JavaScript polyfills like flex EJ assets
yeah harder to get working but it takes
a little more challenge in your content
but it but it is easier than trying to
go do it yourself using you know CSS
float or something yeah right I I would
argue there's enough savings in
developer time to make using flexbox
flexbox polyfills either you know CSS
mix-ins or javascript or whatever hugely
worthwhile okay good then you also
change your audio app to use much one oh
yeah yeah i started at memory as i
started really spending some time with
locks box i was like wow this is so much
easier yeah and as i talked about last
time I think how I started going back
through all of my old audio demos and
recasting them to work well on mobile
and one of them that's actually somewhat
useful on mobile particularly is I did
this audio recorder and it really is
just a demo of how to use this library
record
yes and the live input stream from
getusermedia but the interface was kind
of complex and somewhat awful but it's
really just like I have you know a
microphone that you hit to start
recording and then a save button to
download it to your system and a couple
of visualizers and the the really the
first thing that I really wanted to do
was you have to be able to rotate your
phone I mean this happens all the time
right as you rotate your phone and of
course the easiest thing to do is just
change the stacking way out and move the
buttons over the side because the
visualizers have to be wider than they
are tall which of course makes it hard
to position so I immediately redid them
both flexbox I think it took me like 15
minutes total II rebuild these things
and have and have them adapt when you
rotate using media queries and that
that's a that shows how much easier it
is yeah and they all align properly like
the buttons are centered and yeah you're
gonna last looking I mean especially for
someone who's more more of a beginner
web developer it's so much easier yeah I
was tutoring someone and she was having
a huge amount of problems laying out her
her web page and then I showed her
flexbox and it literally took her took
her i think twenty minutes to redo her
entire app yeah i mean i also have to
keep in mind that what we're trying to
educate people here for is the current
platform that we have and also where
we're headed and you know build the
right set of future skills and i think
by the time you're deploying things that
you've built in this class you'll find
the mix actually is pretty heavily on in
favor of fluxbox yeah absolutely there
are a bunch of other things in the
course that we talked about particularly
in device access that are kind of like
yeah there are these ideas from their
kind of cool and they may work on you
know our Chrome Canary on a particular
platform or something but don't really
use that in production stuff this is
this is really you know this is
supported across all the main browsers
there are always old browsers deal there
is another X
ception that I forgot to mention is that
in Firefox there is a problem currently
with they don't support flex wrap and
flex flow I believe lies already fixed
but it's already fixed so the current
version of Firefox i think is version 26
and in 28 it's it's already fixed so
that's maybe 12 weeks out so it's not a
huge concern yeah yes alright so next
question is from javi in Spain he says
different screen sizes may lead to be
able to fit a variety of Mount of
information into the screen okay but how
can you keep in sync the execution of
code that only affects an area that's
visible in a large screen and hidden in
a small screen so I understand it
correctly maybe sort of the desktop
version of the same single page app and
a mobile version that doesn't show maybe
as many settings or okay yeah I mean
this is one of the biggest challenges
with building a single scalable
application is is pieces of code that
don't execute in one platform in another
one scenario or another or even harder
pieces of code that executes differently
across different platforms I will say in
this particular case it sounds like if
it's not executing in a smaller screen
size or something at all like if it's
just a you know a user control or
something that's simply not there well
it doesn't really have to stay in saying
kids just not not there and make sure
that it doesn't break or cause problems
or obviously you would want to try to
not have that code library downloaded
even because you're chewing up execution
network speed but you know other than
that it's really testing is probably the
best advice I can give yeah and I guess
some of that just gets syncs with the
server anyway right and if it's used in
the desktop app you
we have that instinct for another time
if you're not using it you just don't
yeah presumably the N Sync portion isn't
really that shouldn't be that that hard
it's my keep it in sync on the server
and right if you don't use it you don't
use it okay oh cool so dab in Alabama in
addition to different screen sizes do
you recommend considering different
connection speeds when designing promote
well actually just just touched on that
yeah yeah and don't download this
library you're not going to use that
feature so uh hold that question I don't
really hold that question when when you
get into the performance performance
lesson seven I believe we talked a lot
about different connection speeds and
that sort of thing the big challenge
with this one is of course you should
consider different connection speeds but
more to the point how your app is going
to react in different network
environments and scenarios because it
turns out it's not about well I should
have one version that's for Wi-Fi and
one version that's for 4G because the
world doesn't actually work that way
like you can't just say well i'm on
Wi-Fi so band widths free will i mean i
get this every morning is you know i
will i'll get in the car and i'm in my
driveway and before i actually you know
put the car in gear and take off I check
the traffic because it turns out there's
like three different ways to get to my
office and sometimes one of them is
really bad and so I want to check which
one that the problem is as I'm walking
out the door my phone goes off of my
houses Wi-Fi and goes on to 4G oh yeah
right but somewhere in there like it
takes it a little while to adjust and
sometimes it stays connected but it has
a horrendously bad connection like it's
very very slow takes it a while to pick
up the idea that oh maybe I should just
drop the Wi-Fi and 4G and 4G can be
quite fast so the biggest challenge is
designing for per system where you're
not loading anything over the network
that you don't need to at any given
time and that your app responds well to
these sort of connection degradation one
of the biggest challenges and we talked
about this in in the performance section
2 is looking at what the network status
is it's really hard to even know like
how good your bandwidth this whether you
should be using you know an approach
where you're just jumping you know
dumping everything across the network or
whether you should be cashing everything
yeah and I think that if there was an
easy way to tell that if you absolutely
new bandwidth this free back to your
server right now you know go party on it
then i would say sure you should be
considering the network speed when you
design for it the challenge really is
that you can't know that I mean you have
to know hey I'm on the mobile web and
network bandwidth isn't free but frankly
desktop bandwidth isn't always free
either sure I was staying somewhere over
the long weekend that I had my laptop
out in the the Wi-Fi there but like the
Wi-Fi connection was great but the
actual bandwidth from there to you know
the world basically was really pretty
awful I mean it not really it would lag
and some websites would take just
forever to come up so you know design
your app around that scenario I guess is
the best advice not just you know
consider what your network speed is on
the mobile web but figure out how you
can get your app to run well even when
network is not a consistent you know
high bandwidth connection yeah yeah and
a lot of that again comes back to test
it out on Tyson Edwards test on 3g yes
and there are a bunch of tools where you
can test with different network Charles
proxy yeah i mean great Charles proxy
Rob things like that right yeah so all
right another question from javi and
Spain not exactly on topic but we'll
take a stab at it anyway when deploying
a packaged web app which is the best way
to send data as Jason and load it at
first run in index DB wouldn't that
waste the user's device storage the same
info is loaded twice think of a
dictionary with no server site and not
even too low to data so not sure if
entirely understand it but so it sounds
like the question is you've got a nap
with a bunch of local data so he uses
the the scenario of a dictionary with no
server side so you want a web page with
a big dictionary right in it and what's
the best way to get that data RHONJ a
mobile app i would say i think that you
know for that precise very narrowly
defined dictionary kind of app
dictionary with no update kind of a yeah
hey you can't you can just have a JSON
file that's part of your app part of
your package you know if you're using
app cache it's actually part of the cash
its cash down the system like this is
how we currently do the data for
conference app is it's just a JSON file
embedded in the directory we actually
were getting to to change that because
we do want to update it the reason to
load it into index DB would really be if
you you know it if you want if you want
it indexed if you want to do lookups if
you want to do data manipulation on
right or something like that it would
make a lot of sense if on the other hand
this were something that was getting
loaded over the network and you might
want to update it over time you might
just say you know what I'm going to do
index DB and only index DB I don't have
a JSON file to it could be kind of
useful or sorry wasteful for the the
user's device storage if you had it in a
JSON file and then you loaded it into
index DB could get cleared keep in mind
that index DB can go away he's not
guaranteed to to persist if I go into my
browser settings and I say wipe
everything it's going to wipe that index
DB but it's not going to wipe the JSON
file that's
the server right so the other thing you
can do is just you know when your app is
loaded the first time and it looks in
the index ZB and says hey there's
nothing here or any time that it's
loaded it looks an index DB and says
there's nothing here and it goes and
grabs a JSON file over the network
that's that's another reasonable way to
do it yeah it's good okay cool next
question from QJ in Palestine I've
completed all the exercise and video
successfully but don't feel confident I
have mastered a topic I need more
practice applying the concepts of media
queries and how to apply flexbox can you
recommend some resources so okay yeah so
there are a lot of good resources out
there there are also and you know a lot
of the standard ones I think we've
actually got a wiki page right with a
bunch of external we resources if you
check the class wiki yeah for older
classes we've added additional yeah
reading additional materials a lot of
html5 rocks articles and other things in
terms of getting practice still applying
concepts a lot of that is building your
own projects find for example if you're
applying flexbox find some of the you
know some of your favorite apps that you
use all the time and just look at them
and figure out okay well how would I do
this if I was redesigning it using
flexbox and just try it out I'm even if
it's just as simple as you know a few
different colored boxes that are labeled
you know sidebar navbar all that stuff
that still gives you a pretty good idea
of you know how you would actually
construct it I don't I out level or I
mean if you're if you're looking for
practice applying these what I would
suggest is take your mobile device
browse around for a while find a site
that's broken yeah that doesn't work
well and then just go grab a copy of the
content for that site some you know some
subset of it just save it out to an HTML
file to you know web resource files and
hack on it and figure out how to make it
a good a good presentation
a good adaptive presentation yeah I
think obviously you know the end result
of that is just learning you're not
actually going to republish that that
content right yeah but it is a great way
to figure out how to apply these
concepts into the real world yeah and
the same goes for you don't media
queries and everything too I mean yeah
absolutely anything doing with layout a
great example is find something broken
and fix it yes there's a plenty of
broken yolks out ya know or like you
said just start your own project and
you're gonna be struggling in no time
yeah a network and again if you can't
think of your own project just find
something you like and or you use
regularly and just try and recreate go
through the steps and think okay how
would I do this something you care about
is generally easier to build and
something you aren't going to use I mean
this is this is where the example of
using like reformatting my blog came
from right yeah exactly like huh well
you know what how can I show this
applying this to something that already
exists that's broken oh yeah that's long
gonna happen nice cool SF is asking
another question and up we can probably
take off line a question that he asked
on a forum about the conference app and
didn't seem to work it seems to miss
several files so why don't we take a
look at that offline yeah they don't
they probably at barn as well here but
let's so what we'll take a look at that
today and will post an answer in the
forum question like we did last week
yeah and hopefully that answer was
useful the final question and we always
say that there may not a skill right
well I can't exactly is do you have any
podcast recommendations I have one okay
and it's the web ahead yes i love that
def on gaza Jenna Jenna Simmons does a
fantastic job yeah it's actually the web
ahead was the original one and if she
started talking to I think Eric Meyer
and started saying there's a lot of
history that can help us learn with
future I think you were on I've been on
the web ahead and the web the way behind
I've only been on the web ahead trust me
better that look forward it's getting
better all the time so the web ahead you
can download it in any of their podcast
players earn yeah anywhere you get
podcast so the web behind is just a
version of that so any other I mean
those are big ones I don't listen to a
huge amount of podcasts most of the
stuff that I walk I i generally watch
videos and sore screencasts as opposed
to listen to podcasts well no that's
probably our recommendations kind of not
a it's not a podcast but the chrome
channel on Google developers live yeah I
hear that's great it's not just great
that's awesome that that out for out if
you're looking for videos to the
recorded material from SF html5 is
really good always yeah it wasn't going
to make that particular that web RTC
session yeah so actually you can find
all those on bit ly SF html5 videos yes
so we have over eight hundred eighty
eight thousand views on accountability
so yeah there's a lot of good stuff
check it out turn it up 142 the WebGL
one that's right that's just this
thursday we're having a great WebGL
event for speakers definitely tune in
for that it will be live streamed from
with on GDL so there will be a big one
it's already posted a couple days to go
should be a great great episode now one
thing i wanted to mention that this came
up on twitter as all of these live
sessions that we're doing to live office
hours so we're answering the questions
live but on google developers live the
nice thing is that everything that's
being streamed live is immediately
available for as a recording after the
show is over so that's actually
something you can kind of take as a
the rule of thumb for any episode you
see if it's live you go to that same URL
like even literally a minute or so after
and it's already there in recorded
format sometimes we do a little bit of
trimming of the intro if we run a little
bit of a for example a half hour of
intro music is probably not what you're
interested in that takes 12 to 24 hours
is it right there's that sometimes
that's all you need yeah but yeah so
that's that's how does it work so
definitely we're we're here live you can
ask ask the questions and vote for them
ahead of time and you can do that for
next week's episode already all of these
are up on Google developers live channel
and they will also be recorded and
available later yeah it looks like there
has bit one okay question great okay I
knew it so distant from Dan in Tucson
Arizona my apologies if this has been
already addressed I had a lot of trouble
with the embedded tutorials in lessons
four and five not advancing properly am
i doing something wrong or is a fixed
coming yeah so this is actually
addressed last week too but the main
issue is getting the recordings and
everything done so we've we've recorded
some new material for that it's you know
we need to get it edited and up on the
site it's just it's just a matter of
time and we'll let people know when that
has been updated great cool all right so
well that completes this episode so next
week we're going to be covering lesson
six and seven you can already ask their
questions go to developers that google
com / live / chrome and then you can
find all of the different office hours
sessions we may even bring in some
experts on particular topics I know two
weeks from now you will be out so we'll
see if we can get a performance
specialist in I think I know one yeah
I'm interested to see questions on both
performance and responsive images you
know yes those are those are topics that
are very interesting to me personally
okay well great so with that and we'll
wrap it up and links Chris and Sean
thank you thank you see you next week
see you guys